part of our challenge as teachers is to
help make sure that we're embedding into
their approach enough rigor that we're
looking at the data and the evidence and
that it's being linked to the content
we're teaching here today in the podcast
we're looking at a new kind of
independent study teaching this way is
incredibly rewarding and also really
scary you'll often be invited into
domains we don't have the expertise and
it's quite hard to predict how a given
session or conversation will go welcome
to choc Radio a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare in this episode we'll be
talking about action learning and an
exciting evolution of the independent
study the MIT Sloan School of Management
has a tradition of involving MBA fellows
in collaborations with partners from
around the globe for years these
projects have helped participants build
experience and connections and these
students the MBA fellows are often
already established in a career or in
building their own projects my guest
today dr. Anjali Sastry has led over 100
groups of MBA fellows in these projects
now the thing to note here is that these
projects were developed by the school
and instructors and students would sign
on to work on them but dr. Sastry wanted
to get students more invested right from
the start so she decided to do something
a little different
we'll pick up with dr. Sastri's
explanation this last year I tried a new
experiment where instead of us bringing
in the project's I had students work
with me to create the projects they were
interested in that spoke to societal
challenges that would be important in
the coming decade and that also linked
to technology in some way students come
in with
fashion or a set of questions they're
really interested in investigating could
we take some of the things that work in
action learning traditional action
learning classes and bend them towards
that kind of Drive could I use my own
connections relationships rolodex to
help students follow their passions but
also to find thought partners or project
partners in the world and also tap into
my own expertise and that of other MIT
faculty as well as their peers could you
talk a little bit about some of the
specific projects that students did the
project students did ranged greatly but
all had as a theme using what they were
learning here and tapping into emerging
or existing technology in new ways to
find solutions to problems that faced
many one of my students aleni
came to MIT with completely on fire with
this idea of tapping into analytics and
AI to solve what she saw as a major
challenge when it came to bringing
finance to smallholder and small-scale
farmers she's an expert on agricultural
finance and she realized that in her
native Brazil and elsewhere people who
didn't have good credit standing and
good credit records farmers who didn't
have those assets couldn't get loans and
were forever locked out so there's a big
dichotomy between the people of access
to finance and those who don't
could she break down that barrier in
some way could new forms of data and
technology help do that so instead of
relying only on somebody's credit record
could you look at the weather they're
farming choices their behaviors and
physical data and use it to come up with
a better assessment of the riskiness of
a given farmer from the
point of view slightly technical area
but it actually has huge implications
because it could open the door to all
kinds of folks who are excluded from
traditional finance by providing other
methods of sorting out their riskiness
and their creditworthiness so she's got
drone data map and weather data
behavioral data you know transactional
data and is trying to stitch it all up
in new ways each of these projects
required significant time and engagement
from doctor Sastry I couldn't help but
ask how this all worked what did it look
like to be involved with each student's
project
each project was customized and one of
the things I've learned about trying to
innovate when it comes to teaching is
you have to be willing to invest a lot
the first few rounds the first few years
you do something and then over time you
learn how to make it a little more
efficient streamlined maybe scalable and
more cost effective I learned I had to
keep a white board up in my office with
each project in each person cuz I had
over a dozen running to keep them
straight and try to remember who's doing
what so that when I saw it when I came
into the office I had that person would
be on my mind or that project would be
out of my mind
I do think mundane as it sounds I think
it's also important to have good like
forms and paperwork having people really
articulate in writing briefly what they
want to do and having a structured kind
of update process really helps keep the
momentum and build the focus how do you
measure success and projects like this
it's a great question because students
who are following their passions really
get into it you give them enough freedom
they will have a good time but part of
our challenge as their teachers is to
help make sure that we're embedding into
their approach enough rigor that we're
looking at the data and the evidence and
that it's being linked to the content
we're teaching here so a passion project
by itself may or may not be academic not
every student who comes in with their
passion project is necessarily gonna
want to or should turn it into an
in-depth study so I've learned that you
can't convert everyone and that's okay
because we're offering it this is an
offering of a new learning experience
it's very much driven by the students
interest you need to really be able to
allow the students to self-select in
it's hard to offer something like this
as a requirement so that's another piece
is striking the right balance but
kind of opening the door and inviting
people in versus cracking the whip and
following up on them dr. Sastry pointed
to one of the challenges that she faced
in taking on these students projects and
it's one that many instructors face at
some point how far would she go outside
her area of expertise to support her
students I need to be able to figure it
out for myself and then also be very
clear with the students
how much do I know about the blockchain
that's not an area of my research so how
far do I want to go down a set of
projects that take that on I'm
interested in this topic I'll learn with
you but my domain of expertise relates
to these areas we can apply it to your
questions we can apply systems thinking
or organizational change or business
models to the questions you're
articulating but I am not the technical
expert on this domain so you'll need to
work with someone else on that and
different instructors have different
interests and stepping out of their
comfort zone so that I think that's
really important another big question is
how willing are you as an instructor to
have a mishmash of projects that take on
very different domains teaching this way
is incredibly rewarding and also really
scary you often be invited into domains
we don't have the expertise and it's
quite hard to predict how a given
session or a conversation will go it's
not like running a case where you know
the story and you know what you're gonna
say at each moment in class or you're at
least got a sense of what that might
look like because very often students
will come in and say I've totally
changed my mind and you have to deal
with that so there's both the kind of
personal journey of learning that's less
predictable and the domain part that's
less predictable but you as the
instructor get to set some of
parameters so I want them to not simply
kind of make general arguments about
what should happen but to think about
what they could do as a leader an
entrepreneur an executive if you're
interested in learning more about social
impact technology projects or
independent studies you can find dr.
Sastri's teaching materials on our site
at ocw.mit.edu/donate
sharing their insights about their own
projects additional materials and
instructor insights about project-based
learning are on our educator portal at
ocw.mit.edu slash educator as always
thank you so much for listening we'd
love for your OCW story to become a part
of our conversation use the contact link
in the show notes to share how you use
OCW to shape your own life or those of
others your story will inspire us and
other people and will help us continue
to share the kind of open educational
resources that make a difference until
next time I'm Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare
[Music]
you